committee councillor rayden williams is
the vice chair
we have in attendance this afternoon
senior planning officers together with
officers
from highway from
we have an intense afternoon senior
planning officers together with officers
from legal highways democratic services
and members of council who make up this
planning committee
um for everyone's information the
meeting has been live streamed
and recorded for subsequent broadcast
please can you mute your microphones to
minimize background noise
if you wish to speak please notify me
through the chat facility
and item number one is attendances and
i've got apologies from
councillor win stanley and councillor
morgan
um and i understand um councillor
holden is standing in for councillor
morgan
and he will be joining us later he's
double booked he's got a scrutiny
meeting but he's going to come
as soon as he can after that meeting and
as well
um councillor dr barclay is also
attending
another meeting and she'll be coming
straight after that as well so i'm
very grateful for members coming from
one meeting to a
to a ten dollars i know how busy
everybody is
um okay so i've got a couple of
councilman stanley and i've got um
the minutes of the meeting my item
number three i'm sorry
item number two is declarations event of
interest
members to give notice of any personal
or prejudice
and the nature of that interest relating
to any item on the agenda
in accordance with the adopted code of
conduct any members like to declare
any interest and
i'm aware of an interest declared by
councillor rigby
in relation to the bnq application it's
next door to lancashire
county cricket i understand that council
rigby is a member of lancashire county
cricket club so
we'll um we'll record that interest
declared by
uh councillor rigby i suspect he won't
be taking part in that discussion
um item number three is in minutes to
receive and if so determined to approve
as a correct record the minutes of the
meeting held on the 10th
and the 24th of september 2020 would
anybody like to
move those minutes to the true correct
record i'm happy to
thank you councillor williams um anybody
second that
where else chair thank you councillor
proctor
um item number four is questions from
members of public i'll just read this
this item out it's important it's an
important item
a maximum of 15 minutes will be
allocated to public questions
submitted in writing to democratic
services by 4 p.m
two working days prior to the meeting
questions must be written
must be within the remit of the
committee or be relevant to terms
appearing on the agenda
and two items appearing on the gender
and will be
submitted in the order they are received
and i understand no
questions have been received uh for this
meeting
um item number five is the additional
information report
i hope you've all had sites of that we
had a copy of that sent to us today
and item number six planning obligations
and just before we begin
to discuss that item number six planning
obligations um
just a quick reminder that as well as
our local knowledge
we look to the background papers listed
as a basis for our decision making
this evening so we'll go to item number
six
and that is uh plain obligations
developer contributions towards the
carrington relief flow
road consider to consider the attached
report
of the head of planning and development
and miss kohler
is going to give us an introduction to
this item miss coley
thank you chairman i'll just share my
screen
is everybody able to see that yeah
that's fine
good okay thank you um the report before
members this evening is um a
a focused item to um
that members will need to um note and
then
then approve if they're minded to uh
there will be a vote
on on the item and that's to um
to cover the use of section 106 and
community infrastructure levy monies to
defend the character relief road
and beyond that the methodology for
calculating
section 106 contributions
it's noted and it's reported in the
additional information report that
representations have been made
to members in respect of wider transport
issues in the carrington
area and that includes options of the
route the current relief road
and offices and members acknowledge that
these are important issues
but their future discussion and out of
the scope of this
particular report
equally the decision to whether or not
to direct community infrastructure
monies to the current relief road
would be a future one for the council's
executive and again is out of the scope
of this evening's report
um so a brief introduction to developer
contributions are reminded
to members of the two ways the council
can collect monies from developers
uh to mitigate the impacts of
development the first is section 106
contributions
they're secured by a legal agreement
which would be attached to a specific
planning application
and would be uh and would be to mitigate
the
impacts of that development and that
that could include in
in the case such as such as this of the
character relief road
where the impacts of that that
development are more broad ranging in
terms of improving accessibility
um and require improved infrastructure
for the
area in which the development is is
located
um these section 106 obligations need to
be
six uh three legal tests but they are uh
site-specific and and they are
negotiable
uh the community infrastructure on the
other hand is a set charge on
development
and the the council would adopt and has
adopted a charging schedule which sets
out for
each type of development how much um the
council
is and does charge but for that uh that
charge is not negation
non-negotiable that there are various
exemptions which could be applied
on a site-specific basis but that would
be done after a planning application
is is submitted once the uh once the
charge is made
um the the difficulty with with
um some of the difficulties in funding
the current relief vote have been that
uh up until september 2019 there was no
means
of collecting section 106 contributions
for it
uh the council could only collect
collect community infrastructure levy
and that community infrastructure levy
had been determined
to be directed towards the metrolink was
20 million pounds that needed to be
paid towards that uh and the
council at the uh at around the same
time as adopting its
uh self-charging schedule determined
that that first 20 million
pounds would go um in in that direction
however this change in the law has
enabled
us now to take both section 106 and
the civil muddies towards the same piece
of infrastructure
and that's an opportunity to meet the
current relief road funding gap
now it should also be noticed this is
not a change to council policy that
would
would need to go through the executive
or through full council
but this is a change in the application
of existing policy you'll see in the
report that a number of
uh policies in the course strategy and
supplementary planning documents
are referenced we are applying those
policies
in the light of the change of the law
and effectively rolling back to the
position
prior to 2014 and the adoption of the
community infrastructure levy
so the methodology um for calculating
contributions um is
is set out in the report and is in this
um any complicated formula
basically we're equalizing the
contributions
across all the relevant developments
and um assessing
what the funding gap is which is which
is 12 which is 12 million pounds when
you
take away the sill moneys and then
then calculating that as a contribution
per residential unit
you can then multiply that by the number
of residential units or
100 square meters of commercial floor
space
and get to the overall contribution for
for that particular application so
members might note in the
additional information that appendix one
of your report has been replaced in its
entirety that's because there was an
error
in one figure which had a knock-on
effect on a number of them
and rather than try and identify each
one individually we just wholesale
replaced it but it makes no
difference to the to the methodology or
the fundamentals
it it just makes a difference to the
numbers we use in the example
so in terms of its application it
applies to all major developments in sl5
which is the carrington strategic
location
and would also apply to any development
in the wider carrington and partington
area which would have an impact on the
road network so for example where
we would be at the forthcoming red road
planning inquiry
next week we would we would be seeking
if members are minorities to
prove this even seeking to to apply it
in in this way to that
to that inquiry um it would be a
combination of rampant conditions and
section 106 obligations
which would deliver the contributions
once the council has confirmed it it
would deliver the caring to relief road
so basically the grampian condition says
um
you may do your own mitigation because
we have to give developers the
opportunity to do that but not every
not all of them have have their own
mitigation um
as possible um if you
don't or you're or you prefer to make
the carrying relief road
then we're going to tell you that we're
going to deliver it
um and at that point you pay us the
contributions but you can also
get on with your scheme so and
effectively delivery of the relief road
would be confirmed on the grant of
planning permission for the relief road
not granted planning permission for the
development in question
so there's a potential for a short-lived
relatively short-lived severe impact on
the road network
and you'll see the timetable for the for
the current relief road coming forward
in your report between planning
commission ground being granted
for the relief road and its construction
where
these these developments can get on um
and occupy but but given the way that
development is built and occupied
it's likely likely to be firstly
short-lived because it would be only to
the road was constructed and secondly
a trickle because you know they they're
not going to be all occupied all at once
you're not suddenly going to have 600
homes occupied
um in in a couple of months
so um that's that's a summary and i'd be
uh happy to take any questions that
there might be
thank you miss coley um any members
wishing to ask a question
comment
yeah councillor carey do you like to ask
a question
thank you chairman and this area is
right for development
and grown up in that area and i know
that council
williams spends lots of times in that
area that road is really needed
and i'm just concerned and this might be
out of this remit that
these additional costs might turn away
developers from wanting to
build on there and therefore there will
never be a relief road and then no
development happening there it's a prime
piece of land to be built on that was
that's my only question
could this result in developers turning
away from the
projects um it doesn't seem to be doing
so far
we are in in negotiations with
with i think three currently and
they all accept the need for the relief
road the contributions are coming out
between one and two million pounds
generally which is not actually for the
scale of the development that's being
proposed
uh considered to be disproportionate if
we were asking them all for six or seven
million each then then perhaps
they they would they would be bulking at
that but they are seeing those as
reasonable development costs
anybody else
so really what we're saying here this is
this is a mechanism to uh
to to get the current relief road paid
for which which it needs
needs to happen and um
we've not been able to support it as
well as we'd like in the past this
initiative if you like helps us to do
that and
uh if nobody else wants to speak to it
uh i'd like to go to
a vote because we have you need to vote
on the item and we've got a large
a busy agenda this evening or this
afternoon so would anybody like to
propose
that we support the recommendation
i don't think we're granting it we'll
rather we're supporting it but we do
need to take a vote would anybody like
to propose that we support i'm happy to
propose that
thank you council williams
councilwoman's proposing that we support
the update does that have a second er
thank you councillor property that's
been proposed and seconded that we
support
uh the recommendation um i'll go through
the voting apologies
that it takes us uh such a time but we
have to go through the procedure
so councillor williams are you you're
supporting the uh
proposal yes that's correct thank you
thank you councillor kerry uh yes
chairman i'll support the proposal
thank you councilor stenit
does council stand it here
i don't think he's here okay councillor
holden i suspect he's in scrutiny
councillor minis
happy to support thank you thank you
councillor minis
uh councillor yeah i've moved
virtually
i've listened to the presentation and i
yeah i also approve
thank you very much councillor holden
councillor rigby
councillor rigby are you there
no okay we'll move on counselor procter
support yeah thank you very much
councillor hartley
thank you chair happy to support the
recommendation thank you councilwood
jerome
i also support the recommendation chair
thank you very much
councillor dr barclay has she been able
to
join us no that's fine council
accordingly you'd like to support or
support you you'd like to support thank
you and i'll be supporting
so that's um
nine uh supports and nobody against out
of everybody that's been
present here uh for this item okay so
that
recommendation is supported okay we'll
go to the next item
on the agenda that's a gender item seven
and that apologies for your um
booklet's not being numbered um it's a
bit of a nuisance but there we go
um agenda item seven that's the former b
q
site great stone road in stratford and
mr pearson is going to give us an
introduction to this item mr pearson
thank you uh if you can just bear with
me a minute i will um
look to share my screen with you
can everybody see that no yep that's
good
thank you
zoom in a bit make it a little bit
bigger
okay thank you um
let's be aware from from looking at the
agenda that
um this application is not for
determination as such tonight because
there's been
an appeal against non-determination from
the
from the applicants and so it's before
committee tonight
to to us committee what they would have
done had they been able to determine the
application
so the committee the officer report is
is
on the agenda obviously as we would as
we would normally write it
and you can see that it's recommended
for
uh refusal or that you'd be minded to
refuse the application
uh in relation to the appeal so what
i'll do
i'll just take you through the um the
scheme itself you could see there
on the first slide uh the site down here
in the bottom corner
and you can see the context in that
we've got the metrolink line
the cricket ground the lancaster and
office buildings
and uh great stone road here with the
two-story residential properties
towards the west and also the two-story
development
on the opposite side of the metrolink
line trent bridge walk running along
there
okay just move on to the next slide
um the developments laid out on a podium
underneath which sits at a sort of
uh level minus one a car park that
accommodates
98 parking spaces cycle parking spaces
and waste storage
the ground floor which is the plan you
can see on the screen
that shows the footprint of the building
you'll see it more clearly on um
on a subsequent slide um and also
shows these private uh these courtyards
here
and then private terraces uh on the
outside of some of these
units
the next slide that shows the level 2
floor plan
and you can see that basically this
development
is is formed of just two large building
blocks
now they step back in height from great
stone road
reaching the highest points um towards
the back of the site
and in the southeast corner here um
sort of ranging in height from sort of
five um
six and nine stories at its highest
point over here
the front facade is separated into three
blocks
printing great stone road so you'll see
these elements down in this
in this corner here
just move on to the next slide
there's the first of the of the visuals
for you
um that's taken from uh
great stone road as you as you approach
the site
uh up the hill towards the bridge over
the metrolink line
and i'll just try and skip through these
uh
fairly quickly now you can see the three
blocks fronting the road one there one
here
and one further up
that's the view looking back the other
way so you that's on top of the
metrolink bridge
and you can see here um the sort of
perhaps the one of the greatest impacts
of the development the depth of it
as you look down here running parallel
with the tram line and the height up in
the back corner
but then it's uh kind of appearance as
you look
down uh great stone road
next slide there's a clear review
overlooking the parapet of the bridge
on the metrolink line you can get a feel
for what we feel is the
the excessive bulk and massing of the of
the development there
this one is taken from the sort of back
corner of the site
um the boundary with it with the
lancashire uh
site so you're looking at the rear
elevation along the left here
and the side elevation to uh the
lancashire cricket club
car park just here on my cursor is
move on to the next one and that one is
taken from the cricket grand
carpark i should say so you can see the
the depth of the proposal here there's
just a couple of steps in height a small
one here
and then another one here um one of our
concerns is
the massing and the fact that really
this con this development is just two
large buildings
and the right enough breaks between the
buildings and i think that slide
illustrates
that point fairly well here
move on to the next one there's a couple
of views of the courtyards here
um this is the one which uh the scheme
does
provide for the potential uh for a
pedestrian link
through um towards the
metrolink line should that opportunity
become available in the future
should should the appeal be allowed and
then the top
picture there that's just one of the
courtyards within
within the site
okay that's that shot's taken from
inside the cricket ground um and you can
see
um we've got a couple of the
um cricket grand stands there there's
the player and media center here
um one of the other stands here
the gap here is where you sometimes get
what's known as the party stand quite a
large stand all be
we understand from lancashire's
proposals and the planning permission
that
members were minded to grant uh earlier
in the year
but um that that's unlikely to be needed
in future once that once that stand is
built or it's certainly
unlikely to be to have a requirement for
such a large standard
so at this at this point you can see our
uh the concern that we have in terms of
the impact
we think that development will have on
the visitor experience
to the cricket ground because this is a
fairly large monotonous development
that you see from from that viewpoint
this slide i'm afraid is not that easy
to read
it's so faint it's a cross section um
and i'll just try and illustrate it so
there's great stone road
this is the full sort of depth of the
development along the back of the site
that's adjacent to the metrolink
line here is the
uh the service road at the back of the
site small gardens to the ground floor
units
and then this point here marks the
boundary with lancashire's ground
this line here is extremely fine i don't
think you can see that that represents
the height of the party stand when
that's used
so of a similar height slightly higher
than the party stand
but then as you come further to the
right still
really squinting now this point here
represents the height of the permanent
stand
that's the top corner of it there so you
see there the
the sort of additional height of the
proposed development
relative to that the height of a normal
stands
cricket ground
just moving on again there are a few
slides here from the applicants
townscape visual impact assessment
we have expressed concern about the top
one
you can see this is just across the road
from the other side of
great stone road i think you get a sense
of the massing of the proposal there but
what you don't get of course is an idea
of the height
because unfortunately viewpoint doesn't
doesn't show it
it's shown in in landscape format and
not
a sort of portrait format the low at the
lower bottom slide there you can see
back at ghost crescents the the height
of the scheme you can see
the first the middle and then the other
block or the frontage to the blocks
as they would be seen from great stone
road
and then moving on again again the tenth
temps gate visual impacts assessment
that's from the bridge
what you didn't see on the cgi's earlier
when we looked at that view was the
scale of the development
relative to the scale of the two-story
houses here on the left
on the opposite side of great stone road
so i think that
illustrates quite well why we feel that
this development is
is over is is out of character and is
going to have quite an overbearing
impact
on the people living in these houses of
great stone road
bottom slide there is is the view that
you will get from the tolbert road great
stone road junction
again you get a feel i think for the for
the mass of the development there
and then two other views the top one
that's taken from
from trent bridge walk so you see um
you've got the metrolink line houses
here narrow footpath
the tram line and then the development
proposal of over here on the right and
the bottom slide illustrates the view
albeit a distant view
of of the building in relation to
the longford park conservation area
some images here from the daylight and
sunlight today i appreciate these are
very difficult to see on
on this screen but it it illustrates
um the concern that we have about the
impact of overshadowing
within the courtyards to the proposed
development
um i'll i'll try and take you through
this
these are a series of slides
uh i'll zoom in a bit that might help
taken in in march initially
so this is not so the main building
blocks are there's the arm
that runs um parallel to the metrolink
line
that's the rear of the development
that's the middle section
and then the the element closest to the
cricket ground car park
these dark areas are the other shadows
that are cast by the development
so that's the 22nd of march at nine
o'clock in the morning
and then we move through midday three
o'clock in the afternoon
and six o'clock in the afternoon now
what we feel these illustrate
um is that it's only in
summer really on this
this um sketch here that's midday on the
22nd of june so
when the sun's at it's highest in the
sky pretty much uh
on there you know the courtyards get a
decent amount of sunlight
but our worry is that other than in the
height of summer
residents who are reliant on enjoying
these courtyard spaces
uh are going to be are having to enjoy
them
without the benefit of too much sunlight
which we feel is caused by the the sort
of excessive height
of of the blocks and the form of the
development
i won't go through all those there they
were in the in the drawing pack
um and then finally that's the uh the
final slide
uh and again we've we put that one in
because we feel that that illustrates
the
the context and the relevant and the
relative difference in terms of
of height mass and scale and form
of this development relative to the
houses that you see although
i accept in the distance here on great
stone road
so that's the the scheme i hope you've
got
um a good idea from those slides
just um what the scheme is likely to
look like
the uh just to go through some of our
points laid out in the officer report
principle of the use we consider to be
acceptable
uh and obviously the proposal would lead
to a number of
benefits if the appeal were allowed um
as outlined in paragraph 362 of the
committee report
the benefits include the delivery of 333
dwellings on a sustainable brownfield
site
which would contribute towards the
council's five-year housing land supply
to which we we have to attach
substantial weight
skiing would also result in the delivery
of 34 affordable dwellings and bring
with it
a number of benefits to the local
economy through
temporary construction employment
increased local spending
development would also result in
longer-term benefits to the local area
with um developer contributions towards
open space improvements
facility children young people outdoor
sports provision and highway
improvements
it's also noted that there are no
objections in principle from the highway
authority
the 98 space car park 400 cycled parking
spaces provided within the scheme
however we consider that the adverse
impacts of the development
on the local area significantly and
demonstrably outweigh those benefits
the layout for form the height scale
and massing and the density of the
proposal
are considered to be wholly
inappropriate within the context of the
site
which while sitting adjacent to the
cricket ground and nearby lancaster and
office block
also sits adjacent to two-story
residential plane it's considered that
the proposed development would result in
significant harm to the character and
appearance of the area
to which substantial weight is attached
in terms of amenity substantial weight
is also attached to the overbearing and
dominating effects of the proposed
development
that it would have on surrounding
residential properties in the area in
general
as well as the adverse impacts on
sunlight and daylight
which would result from the development
for both existing and future
residents there's also a level of home
identified to the longford park
conservation area traffic town hall
with minor and negligible harm
respectively
to which great weight is never less
attached
significant weight is also attached to
the harm that would result to the
setting
interest and function of the cricket
club as an important
cultural and tourist attraction which
sits at the heart of the strategic
location
the proposed development complete fails
to comply with the mppf which provides
high standards of design and
sustainability
as a central narrative and the core
strategy in relation to heritage design
and amenity
proposed development also fails to
realize the aspirations
of the strategic location to deliver a
new high-quality residential
neighborhood centered around an improved
stadium at the cricket club
which is an aspiration reflected in the
draft civic quarter area action plan
although it's noted that this particular
document can only carry
limited weight in the determination of
this application
the application proposes the provision
of 10 affordable housing on site
where it's considered that the
application would perform differently to
the generic development
coming forward in the old trafford
market area therefore a contribution of
up to 40
affordable housing should be sought as
part of the application
the applicant has submitted a financial
viability appraisal which has been
independently reviewed for the council
review concludes that submitted
appraisal fails to demonstrate that
proposed development
cannot deliver more than ten percent
before
on this basis it's not considered an
offer of ten percent
probably housing it's policy complaint
proposed development also fails to
contribute towards primary school
prevention in the area
so as a clear reason for refusal has
been identified in relation to heritage
matters
under under paragraph 11 d1 of the mppf
and having carried out weight of
balancing exercise under paragraph
11b2 it's considered that the adverse
impacts of granting this
plan this product planning application
would significantly
and demonstrably outweigh the benefits
of doing so
and so we the application we we
therefore say
uh should be views or members should be
mounted to refuse this
this application in relation to the
appeal that's been lodged
thank you chairman i'll take the
slideshow down
thank you
thank you mr pearson um there's no
speakers to this item understand
are there any statements to be read out
in connection with it
no there aren't chairman no i mean it's
it's obviously this is not an
application for decision
and so it's normal procedure in these
circumstances for
but then not to be speakers either for
or against the proposal
so it's really just for for the
committee to decide whether or not they
they feel they agree with the officer
recommendation
had we been able to determine the
application on this
you know the debate and the decision
that the committee come to
will inform the standards that they get
the appeal
yeah thanks for that mr pearson um any
members wishing to comment on this
application
yes sure um councillor hartley
thank you chair um i mean i i think the
officer's recommendation
is right and i i would agree with it um
and and therefore oppose the appeal i
think i think there's
there's simply too much wrong with the
development that's
that's proposed which is unfortunate
because you know there are some
benefits to it you know provision of a a
lot of housing units which is much
needed
um i know the aspirations in various
draft plans
that have been referred to in the report
is for it to be a you know a new leisure
center in a leisure area but
you know this application has come
forward for housing um
it's brownfield highly accessible
there's a
decent mix of housing um 10 affordable
housing with the potential to be more
had been
in negotiations as has been mentioned um
i think the appearance of the building
is is okay some of the design features
are okay it's similar to what we see in
other applications you know it's a
collection of boxes with some design
features but i do i do
take the point that the you know the
scale and the size the
the massing of it is too much the
development's too dense
it's not it's not broken up um
we saw the the wireframe views which
showed the impact there and
this clear impact on the on the cricket
club um
poor immunity for occupiers in the
development and
and neighbouring properties um i think
landscaping is
a reserve matter but i think given the
scale of the development on the site
that
it wouldn't be possible to have decent
landscaping
there so i you know i'd agree with the
offer officer recommendation
for for those and many other reasons i
mean i think it's a difficult
having lot to do i think it's a
difficult site to develop for
high-density housing because
the cricket club um training hall is
right against one boundary and then
you've got the embankment for great
stone road which
will cast the shadow over over lower
parts of any building so
i think it's probably a difficult site
to develop for high-density housing but
you know i'd welcome
a better quality application that tried
to address some of the deficiencies in
in this
in this application so yeah i'd agree
with the office of recommendation and
happy to move that chair
hartley councillor williams
thank you chad i'm trying to speak at
length given the
amount of items on the agenda this
evening i found myself lost an agreement
with um the sentiments expressed by
councillor hartley
i think what i'd like to say is i think
it's a real shame actually that
we haven't received a higher quality
application come forward because
that being q site has been lying there
dormant for
ages now and i think it's a really
suitable location
um for residential development to be
delivered
especially as councillor hartley said
given that um
it is a brownfield site and i think a
lot of us on the committee really
really value a brownfield first approach
to development
um i actually quite like a lot of the
aspects of the development i think the
graphics that we saw you know the sort
of materials that we used
um potentially it could be quite a high
quality
um build but unfortunately the the
single biggest problem i have is just
the sheer scale of it i think paragraph
101 of the report summarizes
the concerns around the scale the height
and the massing absolutely
perfectly so i i find myself in
agreement with the
officer recommendation particularly
refusal reasons three four
five and six um just
one other thing i'd quite like to
reflect on is that you know i think the
attitude that we've seen
from the applicant in terms of um
the affordable housing delivery and the
viability assessment you know
really i think the message needs to be
clear from trafford and it needs to be
understood by
uh developers that we expect to
fundamentally better
standard from developers who are looking
to
bring forward um property development in
trafford
i think paragraphs 34 and 42 you know
some of the behavior that
summarized in those paragraphs it's
contemptible almost
um so with dutch uh i i will uh formally
move that we um vote in line with
officer
recommendation on this application thank
you chad
thank you councillor williams councillor
minis
thank you chair um i'd like to echo much
a lot before
council williams said i think it's a
real shame because um i think that it
had
had developer wanted to actually work
with the cap with offices and accounts
or
something much far more appropriate
would have been put forward
and the the massing is it's huge isn't
it
it's it's really huge and i know that
like you know
whether you think it's a beautiful
building or not a beautiful building in
the eyes of the holder but i think
many of us can probably agree that you
know a large box there is probably not
the best thing to be looking at when
when given the area that it's in um
the the fact that they've not i mean i
think lack of consideration of schools
if you're going to have families in in
the hair you need somewhere for the
children to go
to be educated you're going to have you
know an increased population
there's lots of things that haven't been
thought about let's just say and almost
um things that have been you know have
been given consideration let's say cycle
spaces which i i do like
um but they you know it's like they've
given they've put it in certain things
but then
you know the rest of it hasn't the whole
thing hasn't been looked at
the light i was really quite disturbed
but that was a really really lovely
look well presented given that we're all
on screens um
part of the presentation um because with
the light we
as we know with uh reduced daylight and
you're only getting any
sort of decent daylight you know um
daylight there in the in the peak of
summer
um as shown in those diagrams then then
you know i think people's mental health
will suffer
and so there's no way in which i can
support this i will be going with
the officer recommendation to refuse
thank you very much
thank you councilman councillor carey
thank you chairman um i at the minute uh
don't support the officer's
recommendation
i've been listening to to the counselors
hoping that they might be able to
change my mind and they they haven't yet
and i i don't
agree with the balance um regarding
education which i thought was a really
good point that counselor minister
brought up
uh there is there are
another there's another project on
tonight in the same sort of area
there was another one on the other week
this could introduce over a thousand new
families into the local area
secondary school seems to be okay but
the primary provision still is not good
enough on a
i know this is nothing to do with this
committee but we do need an education
plan for primary school places in the
borough
um but the minute i am in support of
uh of allowing this this process to take
place so i'm getting the words milled up
there
and unless i hear some more things come
through thank you
thank you chairman thank you councillor
kerry council accordingly
um thank you chair um yeah broadly in uh
agreement particularly with uh council
williams
um i do think it's uh a balanced
decision
um i am in support of the principle of
the development
um i'm a bit disappointed by lancashire
if i'm honest and i think
i guess they'll be listening to this but
i don't think they're making their case
particularly strong
um their alternative is consolidated
uh car parking which sounds very much
like to me a multi-storey
and i will be very upset in a few years
time if um
we've refused this in favor of a
multi-story car park
of a similar scale because there's
plenty of aspects of this design that
are good
but it's not good for the people that
live in it
that's the trouble because it's too
compressed and camped
uh and the shading i'm not totally
i i think it's an except it's almost
acceptable for
the houses opposite i think we over play
they're quite a distance away
uh i think we're overplaying that and
there's some high rise quite a lot of
high rise already in the
district and the people live with quite
acceptably
but i think it's a touch too high so i
think there's um
there's a potential in this project
with amendment to make it a really good
project
which i would vote for but we're not
there yet
and um yeah and i think that's all i
would want to say i think we
i notice our reasons for refusal we put
the lancashire cricket club at the top
of it
and maybe it doesn't count as the main
reasons maybe there's no hierarchy
it does bother me that they're out there
at the top because i see the main reason
as the the effect on the future tenants
the people that live there
because i think it is cramped it is
denied sunlight
there isn't much facility in there and
it has a
real potential on the current design to
deteriorate over the years
uh thank you chair thank you council
accordingly
um there's nobody else wishing to speak
i've just briefly commented myself
um perhaps picking up what council
accordingly is saying
and perhaps disagreeing with council
according to this is such an important
site to me and
um um you know it it
really is it's virtually next to us at
the town hall and
it's so important and i just feel that a
more strategic
approach is required and when i say that
what i'm getting is
everybody working together and if the
developer was working
with lancashire and and got agreement on
what they were doing it would just
it would just make me more comfortable
with anything that that they
potentially brought forward um
all the developments in this area will
will reflect and balance with each other
and
so we need to work together and but it's
it's evident from me that lancashire
are very much against this and um i i i
only wish people could be working
closer together to uh to to bring
applications forward
and that that would be successful and
certainly would have the potential
to be successful um so i'm going to go
to a vote now
and i think did councillor williams move
that we refuse the application or
mandatory i think he did
and um is that am i correct in saying
that counselor williams
that's correct yes yeah and would
anybody like to second that
uh proposal i'm happy to thank you
council accordingly
so for the reason set out in the report
um
we're going to take a vote on refusing
the application there's no
alternative um proposals so
bear with me again chairman we're not
refusing we're minded
to refuse apologize for that not an
actual application
yeah yeah thank you thank you miss
clifford we are minded to refuse this
application we're taking a vote
and being minded to refuse um council
williams how would you like to vote
commanded to refuse in line with officer
recommendations thank you very much
councillor carey how would you like to
vote
if i get this the wrong way around
please excuse me i'd like to vote
to mind it to grant or not minded to
refuse
that's fine we understand councillor
kerry thank you
councillor stennett it's council
standing here
no council stan is not here okay
councillor holden
are you here i'm here minded to refuse
man to refuse thank you councillor minis
how would you like to vote
thank you chair minded to refuse thank
you thank you
um councillor rigby are you here that's
the rig there
councillor wouldn't be taking part in
this um discussion and obviously because
he previously declared an interest in
the item he's an actual member of
lancashire
so we'll uh we'll not ask for a vote
from councillor would be
councillor procter how would you like to
vote agree with minded to refuse
thank you council proctor councillor
hartley thank you chair agree with the
uh recommendation monitor reviews
thank you councillor jerome thanks jay i
also agree with uh off the
recommendation minded to refuse
thank you councillor dr barclay oh i'm
guessing is it still at scrutiny council
accordingly
i need to refuse thank you and
councillor walsh
and myself is managed to refuse so
that's one two three four
five six seven eight volts money to
refuse
one vote minded to grant so that
application is
minded to review refuse sorry for
getting my word in incorrect
everybody okay we're going to go to the
next
application and that is land founded by
elsinore road and skirting road
and uh some of your agenda papers are
actually numbered it's
uh going towards the end of that first
bulk and
actually page number one um
[Music]
as i say it's uh an elsinore road
and um
is going to give us an introduction to
this item miss lowe's
thank you sir i'll just get up the
[Music]
presentation
which was until recently occupied by
various large industrial buildings and
silos
but it's now largely cleared and the
slide upon the screen at the moment
shows the site
outlined in red and you can see this was
before
back and before the application site was
cleared so you can see the extent
and um nature of the industrial
buildings that did exist on the site
previously
and to the east of the site you've got
in the local center here
of empty mo grove and the wider context
of the site is mixed in character
of commercial users as i say the local
thing here
um an existing bakery used here at the
link
in depot area here over to the west
and aim a number of residential units
you've got a 93a residential block here
um a grove house and which you've
converted from
from offices and you've got two story
and residential
to the south or you can stay in
properties online growth at the bottom
of the screen here
there's two stories and there's a
distance of nine meters from the back of
these properties
to the application bound this was an
application boundary
and to the north of the site of talbot
road
and bowling club and just here on on the
in the western side
in the next set of slides the next slide
and includes some pictures of the
site previously the previous industrial
use and you can see there's a large
number of residential
um industrial buildings and with silos
extending across extensive sites and
this this image at the bottom
aim is the view of center street site
and you can see how the
the buildings and previously extended
across
um
the development commission aimed for 367
residential units on the site
and laid out in five blocks and of
between six and ten stories in height
and comprising one two and three bedroom
units
and the blocks um are laid out in block
a and it is along elsewhere road here
and that would be a maximum of seven
stories
it's attached to block b here and by a
single story
um edition and this would um step
up from stories on the corner here eight
stories
and then ten stories across the station
road and opposite the the local center
here
look um something on the implicated road
and tennis street would be six storeys
and these two blocks at the back of the
site would be seven stories
the idea of the design rationale in in
regards to these um
in regards to the site to try and create
the day of the street
and within the development and the
development fronts
well onto skating road and elvenar road
and creates these two street fronts of
the site all
the ground floor units within the
development would have individual
entrances and accessed
individually at ground floor level um or
would have
areas of essential oil central space in
front of those
um increasing along skerton road and
elsewhere road
and you have a series of town houses
either at um the first two stories or at
one storey
um and and these all have a lens
individual parking spaces off streets
small front garden areas and on item and
landscaping with integral bin store air
design of the building um i've tried to
incorporate some of the historic
character of the area drawing on the
villas of the wider
albert road area and the south in terms
of the residential area
and include hunted bays and and and
looks like and there's a consistent
theme in climate design across the site
with
minor variations in equinox and suits
and the individual needs of the block a
high quality palace of material is
proposed
and that is um contrast with what's out
for the aip
in a wider area so as i talked about
found houses are provided
um along the front of the skate and
elsinore road this
image shows a little bit of a close-up
plan of how that would look
as you can see um units would have their
individual car parking space
entrance into the site a small area of
amenity space to the front
in google bin stores which will be built
out of brick mat
that's half of the main building and
planters and on the landscaping
um to provide features
and the image that just flashed up on
your screen then is a tpi of what these
townhouses would look like along the
main street front
of the site and as you can see they have
the county bays
the interesting and window detailing
and the interval being storage areas
here the landscaping
car parking spaces and as you can see
the bay is kind of step forward as the
main block
and trying to really um address the
street frontage give some sort of
present
bring domestic scale to the overall
development um of the life
and the variations of these townhouses
all around the building
all around the development i would say
um
as they address the sweet front of this
and within the individual streets are
created within the site
and this image just shows you the
different variations of
the townhouses and the slight variation
in design
and i think it's really important to
know that there is real articulation
and detailing within these um in these
blocks
and it's really been thought about how
to bring these and these developments
that add under street presence and
street flankers
the development will also provide two um
main vehicle and pedestrian entrances in
space
and one here of skirting road and worn
here off elsinore road
and whilst they're both vehicular and
pedestrian pedestrians will be given
priority across the site
and how this is proposed through a high
quality
and palace of hardline vaping materials
and as you can see this kind of um
peaky color is proposed to be a high
quality pavis
um with small areas of tarmac
and the areas which will be used by cars
and the individual parking bays which
highlights them
in a different surface material can
really bring some interest
and vibrancy in terms of hard
surfacing to move away from the black
top area
and enhance the landscaping there the
proposal um
provides 67 car parking spaces on site
and as i said all of the
the properties that i've gone through in
the existing streets have
individual off street car parking that
are privately
that are private for themselves and they
all have euv touching points
and the individual private spaces and
then there's one every ten spaces in the
communal
car parking in addition to five
accessible parking spaces
further through this what is proposed to
be secured through a section 106
agreement
is the review of the tarots in the area
and to ensure that the development
doesn't have a significant impact on
parking within the wider area
in a similar way to what we secure case
site last
at last committee in terms of in parking
strategy and trust management within the
area
the scheme also includes um some
communal
courtyard space and an open space within
the team
and this is proposed in a central area
here
in addition to that there is an internal
aim clubhouse that's proposed to provide
internal amenities space for residents
the outdoor space includes um
landscaping grass areas outdoor seating
and informal play and will be for the
benefits of the residents
in addition to that there is a gym
proposed as well
landscaping and biodiversity measures
biodiversity measures that
measures are also posed across the site
and as you can see on this plan which is
the landscaping plan you can see the
extensive
replanting and soft and hard and
landscaped areas
the key issues for consideration which
were addressed in the report
are the principle of developments the
design and impacts on the streets being
inherited assets
residential amenities highways impacts
open space
landscaping and developer contributions
it's concluded in the report that this
is a high quality development
which would create mixed community in a
highly sustainable brownfield location
and it would relate well to the wider
area
which was mixed in character it is
considered that the variation height
across the site is appropriate
and not excessive in views in view of
the site-wider context
identically responds sustainable urban
location
also includes public realm and communal
open space areas
including incorporating native species
and
biodiversity enhancements within
landscaping the development would not
impact on the amenities of existing
residents and due to the significant
separation distances involved
the scheme would be energy efficient
propose low communist driven usage
and give priority to pedestrians the
considered to be an appropriate response
to the site's sustainable urban location
we're noting that there will be no
impact on health infrastructure and
facilities within within the immediate
area
and it has been considered existing
facilities would be able to serve any
future residents
this is the same also for secondary
school provisions
contributions of of 500
000 pounds are sought towards primary
school places in the local area
contributions towards a wider open space
where all have sought
however the applicants demonstrated that
this would not be viable
while the small number of adverse
impacts have been identified within the
report
including some less than substantial
harm to the setting of the old rapid
bowling club and non-designated heritage
asset
a managed footfall in the quantity of
site open space
and the lack of financial contributions
towards this the scheme delivers
an extensive number of benefits
including the significant contribution
the team would make
the council's five-year housing land
supply including the addition of
10 affordable housing on site high
quality and well-designed
development the economic and
regenerative benefits
divided by landscaping improvements and
the financial contribution
of 573 000 pounds towards primary school
provision in the area the development is
considered
compliance with the development plan
however in the context of the
healthy balance which is engaged in
guard the scheme
is considered to signif significantly
and demonstrably outweigh those minor
adverse impacts identified
and unlock this offers our recommending
refusal
thank you
thank you miss laws um sorry me uh
your pictures my friction is frozen
there
um you said officers were managed to
refuse i think you meant officers or
money to grant miss lowe's you know
that's fine
tonight that's okay thank you we've got
three
speakers against this um night we've got
two councillors
and um we've got miss o'connor missile
connery are you here to speak
do do we have a miss o'connor yes hello
can you hear me
yes we do thank you you have three
minutes miss o'connor
hello um i've been a resident of old
trafford and first for the past 16 years
and i very much love my local area
community
i appreciate the fact that there's been
um some plans made for the area near
lime grove where i live
but i'm horrified at the lack of family
homes included
and i'd like to reference the trafford
local plan with regard to my
objections please accept my apology if
i've made any errors with regard to my
interpretation of their plans
i'd like to ask about section l2 to
bracket c of the trafford local plan
which states
all new developments need to be not
harmful to the character or amenity of
the immediate surrounding area
it's my assertion this proposed
development will bring harm in a number
of ways
it's out of keeping with the local area
there have been numerous recent high
bill
rise developments and therefore it could
be argued that this
type of development and the need for
this type of accommodation has already
been met
and we would welcome a development that
was predominantly low rise for example
like that
on the side of the former fgr and sun's
factory on prestige street in old
trafford
the development will also bring
additional levels of congestion and
pollution that would impact hugely on
the area
anybody who has uc more growth around
tea time during the week will appreciate
that navigating this area around this
time is very difficult
i also understand that there are only 67
parking spaces proposed for this
development and therefore
we might expect that there could be
upwards of 700 people living in this
space potentially
i worry about this in relation to
general moving around the area but also
on match days
it's my understanding that local school
provision is already heavily
over-subscribed and
therefore new families moving to this
area may find it difficult for their
children to access
education this may also be the case for
local gps dentists and other services
that
communities require i'd also like to
reference section l27 of the trafford
local plan which states that one bed
general needs accommodation will
normally only be acceptable for schemes
that support the regeneration of traffic
town
centres and the regional centre in all
circumstances the delivery of such
accommodation will need to be
specifically justified in terms of a
clearly identified need
my assertion that proposed 175
one-bedroom units that are referenced in
this plant are not in keeping with local
need
according to the local plan the trafford
housing market appraisal of 2006
shows a need for family housing across
the borough
in section 11.4 page 95 it states the
broad definition of family housing
will include larger properties brackets
three bedrooms and larger
as well as smaller two-bedroom houses to
meet a range of family circumstances
from the proposed plans the predominant
form of dwelling offered is one bedroom
flats with only five properties proposed
that are two or three bedroom houses
it is my view that this ratio is
completely out of keeping with the needs
of the local community and in turn the
local plan objectives with regard to
meeting housing need
i would also like to reference section
11.4 of the local plan
which states that there is a need to
meet the requirements of specific
cultural and religious family needs this
will include the development of larger
family homes
therefore it must be argued that any
future development must include
many many more two to three bedroom
houses and in fact should represent a
significant proportion of proposed new
units
i would therefore be grateful for the
committee's views on my objections and
whether or not the proposals are in
keeping with
the local plan
thank you miss connor um
councillor duffield are you there
i am chair thank you very much
you have five minutes counselor field uh
thank you chair for allowing me to speak
this afternoon and raise some of the
issues that i've received from
local residents about this application
and while it is noted that one of the
blocks has been reduced in height by one
story there are 13 fewer homes than the
original application
and the threshold 10 percent of
affordable homes on this site has been
met
i've still received numerous objections
from local residents
23 objections have been have been
received this is amongst the highest
amount that i've ever had for a single
application and reflects wider disquiet
about the changing nature of this part
of old trafford
without any quality or strategic
consultation with those people who've
called the area home for many years
local residents feel that the area has
had higher residential buildings imposed
on it in recent years with nearby
office to residential developments
taking place as committed development
further development at height and block
b here is concerned with its impact on
local residents
is not in keeping with the local area
which is in the main traditional family
type housing
we know that overcrowding and some poor
family homes exist in old trafford
and what local people would like to see
is better quality houses and not
apartments
as more land is used for apartments and
the area will continue to change without
the views of local people being heard
as we as we know there are other
applications for higher buildings in
progress that are further away from the
more traditional areas of old trafford
which deserves development that can keep
people from
housing they want local residents feel
that this application over develops the
site with 367 homes only slightly less
than the original application
it starts to hem in nearby roads such as
lime grave a road that i've received a
large number of the objections from
and many people feel that nothing has
changed of any substance from the
original application
local residents also object to this
application due to the inadequate amount
of parking with just 67 spaces for 367
homes
just one space for every five homes
believe that they will be heavily
impacted by extra on-street car
traffic and spd3 states that for this
location
each one-bedroom home has one space and
each two or three bedroom home requires
two
which would be 400 spaces because 67 is
a compromise
of too big an impact on the local area
this repeat
report note that this area already
suffers from commuter and match day
parking pressures
and while we would like to think that
people will live here without a car
which is all conceivable
so many people would and therefore she's
felt that this would be an unacceptable
burden for local people
we also have to take into consideration
those office to reside developments
along with the new build at trafford
plaza that already do not have enough
parking
adding to this issue is a major reason
why this application should not be
granted
while the submitted transport assessment
saves a census that was 10 years ago
says apartment living has 75 percent of
people living without a car
it is felt that relying on evidence from
so long ago is not acceptable
a different demographic that this
housing is aimed at would bring a
different result
there were no similar development at
height locally ten years ago to compare
with and therefore this assessment is an
invalid piece of evidence to use and
should not be taken into consideration
by the committee
while we support the active travel
agenda it's naive to think that 67
parking spaces will be enough
we wish it would be but there is no
recent evidence to suggest this
getting on the tram at trafford bar at
rush hour can be challenging and buses
do not use this part of tolbert road
the offer of mitigations from the
developer is not acceptable to local
people
and while the highway authority may
reluctantly accept less than 25
provision and this is a long way below
that at 16
it is noted however that the local
highway authority is still not happy
with this proposal
and i highlight the paragraphs of 282
and 374 to the committee
paying for a parking review does not
resolve the issue should this
application be granted however we would
wish to see in which title legal
agreement
that would ensure the provision of
funded resident parking schemes
including permits
it is disappointing also that in the
changing nature of the last few months
and the reliance on good quality outside
space
that this development also falls short
of the levels set out in the core
strategy
but quality space does not make up for
the lack of it it is disappointing that
the submitted viability appraisal does
not see that contribution to open space
provision is affordable
with an extra potential 600 plus
residents in the vicinity
committee should take into consideration
that proposed provision does not comply
fully with spd one in this regard
the report would state that this will
result in some adversity should be given
to this by the committee
felt that this application is too high
and dense out of keeping with this part
of old trafford
it does not allow for enough parking and
does not have enough open space within
it
and with no mitigating contribution this
is not acceptable to local residents
we would ask the committee to take this
information into consideration
and refuse this application thank you
chair
thank you councillor duffield councillor
german are you there
hi aren't you yes councillor gentlemen
you have five minutes
okay thank you chair for letting me
speak and thanks to the committee
so obviously i'm speaking against this
application
i've got to take issue with a lot of
what the planning office has said
i'm not against the the development of
this site
with it being an appropriate development
and i strongly support the greater
manchester spatial framework
and the sympathetic development of this
brownfield site in this residential area
this proposal is simply too tall and too
dense and
out of keeping for this area of old
trafford
where the surrounding residential
properties are predominantly
two-storey terrace and townhouses
this has only been reduced by one claw
from the original
application back in march which which
really makes
very little difference to the outcome
and i think there is definitely an issue
with these type of city center type
developments creeping into old trafford
old trafford is a low-rise residential
area
and i think this proposal um we have
with this proposal we've come to a
watershed and if we accept this
application
we've stepped over the line of a policy
threshold in my view
so when it first when it first was
raised back in march it was suggested
that we
we got a meeting with the local members
residents senior planning office and
offices of the council
to decide whether we needed a policy in
the in this area to decide what was
acceptable what
was not acceptable obviously then we
were hit by the cold grid
lockdown everybody working from home
um getting used to a different way of
working and obviously new priorities so
it didn't it didn't actually didn't
actually happen
there are there are some complementary
low-level developments in old trafford
has been already mentioned such as the
the juro's site and prestige spree
this is the type of development we
should encourage as the local authority
the only place in old trafford that we
should perhaps consider an
application of this type is in the civic
the civic quarterback between talbot
road and the tram depot
to the east of the cricket ground
this development is so close to houses
there would be a danger of overlooking
despite what the developer says there
certainly would be a loss of light and
also very little green space is
supported
is supported with this application
clearly 67 parking spaces is totally
inadequate
for this development and while whilst we
were looking forward to a sustainable
transport revolution
we know that it's not going to happen
overnight and we will require a cultural
change
the volume of traffic generated by this
will add to the already stressed road
system especially around the junctions
not to mention the negative impact on on
the environment
the visual aspect of the building also
is not particularly pleasing to the eye
and the tower blocks look pretty drab
there's also been a lot of comments
about the lack of balconies
in the development this seems to be a
gross omission
by the architect in my view
however the developers should be given
credit for
agreeing to the minimum standard of 10
um for the affordable housing element
but
but this but the committee shouldn't be
swayed by this
as it's just not the right application
for this site
a large number of residents are clearly
against this application
and saying that development of this size
and scale
is just not acceptable on this site and
if you compare it with the
previous item of the bmq site i think
the relative
uh scaling of the
proposal to the to the to the
surrounding area the two-story houses
is is much the same argument but in on
this site
it's much much increased scale because
of the
the sheer scale of the development
so i would i would urge the committee to
reject this application
thank you
thank you councillor chairman um do we
have missiles
speaking in favor of the application
hello
yes thank you you have three minutes
missiles
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to speak today
we strongly believe in the quality of
the proposed scheme and design the ethos
behind the proposal
tim groom architects are one of the
north west's top architectural practices
who design
great buildings not only in terms of
aesthetics but also in terms of
livability
the heights of the blocks at 6 8 and 10
stories are considered appropriate
in the surrounding context buildings of
this height and taller can be seen in
the immediate local area
and it's considered that this
appropriately balances the impact on the
street scheme
with the need to provide a high density
development in this sustainable location
the scale and design quality enables the
site to contribute to the creation of a
vibrant community
taking advantage of a sustainable
location adjacent to a local centre
and with an easy reach of manchester
city centre
the scheme delivers 367 new residential
units on a brownfield site
in a sustainable location within an
urban area
significant weight should be afforded in
the determination of this application to
the scheme's contribution
to addressing the identified housing
shortfall and meeting the government's
objective
of securing a better balance between
housing demand and supply
at the core of what the proposed
development is trying to achieve is a
sense of community and neighborhood
it seeks to diversify the existing
housing offer in the area through the
provision of a mix of housing types
including apartments and townhouses we
envision that the scheme will appeal to
young families
professionals and graduates this mix of
occupiers means that we've included
different housing typologies to suit
varying lifestyles
for example the inclusion of larger two
three bed apartments
offering space for growing families with
on-site community space
allowing children to grow a sustainable
and stimulating environment
there are also double and single-story
townhouses which offer a different type
of accommodation for families
for young professionals the scheme will
provide apartments
alongside working and amenity space in
addition to encouraging community and
street activity
central to the success of the scheme are
high quality green space and landscaping
they soften and articulate the built
form providing an
enhanced experience assisting with wave
finding and providing immunity space
the proposals reinstate the idea of the
club back into the site by introducing
the new lawn club a multi-functional
space that can be used by the residents
as a place to meet and gather
the central courtyard and external areas
have been designed as simple
multi-functional species that allow
flexibility and can be easily adapted to
different residents needs the
landscaping scheme includes over 5000
square meters of amenity space
152 trees native and wildlife friendly
species of planting
green and brown roofs bug hotels and bat
and bird boxes
enhancing the on-site biodiversity the
proposal also includes electric charging
vehicle points
one for one cycle parking and commits to
carbon emissions at least 30
below building regulations daylight
sunlight
overlooking wind noise inflation
and air quality have all been fully
assessed by officers
and the results considered policy
compliant in terms of parking the
overarching designs concept of this
development relies on low carb
ownership and this has assisted in
providing pleasant streetscapes within
the site
by avoiding large sways on stanley
given the site's highly sustained
sustainable location
sustainable methods of transport are a
genuine option for journeys
and it's considered that this site
typifies the thrust of the mppf
to focus significant development in
sustainable locations
in order to help reduce congestion and
emissions and improve air quality and
public health
in relation to affordable housing the
scheme provides 10 affordable housing on
site which will be secured via section
106 agreement
full education contribution given the
overall policy support for the proposals
the many benefits it will bring we hope
you can support the scheme and approve
the application
thank you thank you very much miss ellis
and i'm going to say return to your seat
but i'm sure you've already sat down
um miss lowe's would you want to come in
on some of the issues raised by miss
o'connor yes i can
um yeah what i've done is i have um i've
just
pulled up the um accommodation schedule
um
and what the first thing to note is that
we are happy with the mixed
residential um there is a high
proportion of one and two bed
units but in this location in a highly
sustainable location we consider that to
be acceptable
and that's being accepted by our um
housing strategy and growth manager
and but there is also good proportion of
in three bedroom units and
in large two-bedroom units within the
in the scheme we have 23 in
two-story two-bed town houses we have
um seven two story three bedtime houses
and 49
three bed apartments and which is
considered to be an appropriate mix and
create a sustainable and mixed community
so we are we are happy with mix in terms
of the units
proposed thanks miss lawson for sure
other issues that miss o'connor brought
up will be
in the um in the discussion with members
um we're happy that the
the proposal is policy compliant i think
that's what she was getting at and she
was able to quote
actual page numbers of policies for us
but we're happy with that the
interpretation of the applicant
she quoted policy l 2.2 and
see which was around i'm not harmful to
the character or menacing of the
immediate surrounding area and where we
are happy that it relates
to the character of the area and does
not impact on residential amenities
and as mentioned in my presentation the
reasons 90 meters between the custom
boundary of the application site
and the properties on lime growth and
considerable
new other residential industries within
a wider area
and over 30 to 40 meters so yes we are
happy that there is not that is possibly
complying
thank you very much miss lowes would any
members wish to comment on this
item any council's wishing to speak
uh well why are you just thinking about
what they want to speak oh councillor
hartley you'd like to comment council
hartley
terry chair thank you i i think this
this
application's finally balanced actually
i think i think the
you know the report concludes that the
benefits um
you know demonstrably outweigh the um
the adverse impacts
i'm i'm less sure about that myself so
i'm actually
probably undecided but i'm not i'm not
convinced that
we should be minded to grant uh at the
moment there's some there's some really
good features in the application
um you know some of the design features
are good the the idea of the town houses
is quite good i quite like that
it creates active frontages the club
outside is good some
good uh some good quality landscaping
except that it's delivering a lot of
housing units which is obviously much
much needed uh there's a 10 affordable
housing
um provision um
but in some ways that's disappointing to
be honest i i
i know each scheme and the viability of
each scheme you know is gonna
is gonna vary from scheme to scheme but
uh
you know we looked at a similar
application just previously in a site
that's not very far away
and you know the the commentary in that
report was that we should be pushing for
for more than the 10 affordable housing
so the location is very nearby same
market conditions so
i'm having difficulty you know squaring
those two things so really
um you know i'd want to see more than
more than 10
affordable housing um i like the fact
that um
the accessibility is good that um
that all the all the apartments i think
can be made um
dda compliant i think that's good uh the
parking still concerns me i think the
the 67 spaces doesn't seem enough
um i think the report does all it can to
set out how that can be mitigated uh car
ownership
you know uh is lower um
i think has mentioned that residents
wouldn't be eligible for parking permits
um there's the does the section 106
agreement to secure funding of
surveys and uh and tros if if need be
um and it's a good development of a
brownfield site which you know which is
which is which is welcome um
i i think i i mean i think looking at
the conclusion of the report
though i do what what does bother me is
that i think
some of the benefits of the scheme so
these are paragraph 36376 of the report
i think i think a lot of those are a
repetitive to be honest so we've
we've got the benefits there about the
delivery of 367
homes 10 affordable contribution towards
education facilities
well-designed development um and then
the next one is about
maximizing benefits of a brownfield site
which which i think is already covered
um there's one about the social
environmental benefits associated with
the
provision of on-site open space
well yes there are benefits to that and
it and it looks like good quality open
space but it's not adequate open space
so i'm not sure that can be properly
viewed as a benefit of the scheme
and an improved pedestrian cycle
connectivity i couldn't
really see how the scheme provides that
obviously the amount of
cycle parking is is welcome so i think i
think it's
quite quite finely balanced um to be
honest i think the
the lack of the contribution towards
open space i think
is is disappointing um and i think the
the lack of the contribution to outdoor
sports provision also disappointing d
we know the playing pitch strategy for
trafford highlights there's already a
shortage of
outdoor facilities and and playing
pitches and
you know time and again we're approving
developments like this that are making
no contribution to to improving that
that picture
and i suppose that one of the main
things that probably concerns me about
it is
is i thought what miss o'connor said was
quite persuasive actually about
about the housing mix and there's a lot
of
one-bed apartments in the in the
development
and uh i know i know miss lowe's
addressed this
i think in part but i think what miss
o'connor referred to as well was
uh l 2.7 in the in the core strategy
which
which says that one bed apartments will
normally only be accepted for schemes
that support the regeneration of
trafford's tone centers in the regional
center um
and delivery of such accommodation will
need to be specifically justified
and and i'm not sure it has been in the
in the report um
so my initial reaction on looking at it
was there was a lot of good in the
scheme
i think the design is is quite good i
don't think it's as
um you know as outstanding as maybe the
report suggests but it's
it's not bad design but so that was my
initial reaction it was good to see this
site being developed but i think
at the moment i do have a lot of
reservations about it and i'll happily
listen to what the members say to see if
um you know those reservations get uh
get resolved in some way
uh thank you chair thank you councillor
hartley and before i bring in
um another counselor can i just miss
laws is going to come back to us and
talk about
affordable housing ms lowe's
yes i just wanted to clarify and the
point on affordable housing that council
are hardly raised
and in this location at the cold market
area and in
good market and policy compliance is
10 and it does comply with policy
in in that regard in reference to the
bnq site
and it's because we expect to be
includes like something differently
through generic developments within the
within the wider area given that it's a
mixed use development of residential and
commercial so hence why we think that
will will um
perform differently and we think we can
get more out of that this one we don't
think will perform differently
standard high dense residential
and on that basis we've considered 10
affordable housing to be policy
compliance
thank you miss lowes uh councillor
williams likes to comment
thank you sure um i think similarly to
councillor hartley i um initially
felt quite enthusiastic about this
development um
when i was sort of looking on the
planning portal and reading through the
report
and i think unusually this evening we've
received three
really quite robust representations uh
from
councillors duffield and german and also
ms o'connor and i really
you know i just want to put on my thanks
for
um the quality of the statements that we
received because it
has made me think again i think um
there are a large number of aspects of
this development that i
really feel enthusiastic about i like
similarly to the discussion we had on
the preceding item i like the fact that
it would be a brownfield first
approach to development um i think that
we had a discussion at the last
committee meeting about
the case site and uh my thinking around
the mix
of the housing type in the development
is is quite the same
i like the fact that potentially a sort
of intergenerational community could be
um fostered here at this site and i
think that that
really speaks to uh such a
changing nature of trafford and also um
an evolution in the way that people are
starting to live their lives and
and in how communities i've organized
um i also think that when when you
looked at the
cgi graphics that the developer has
provided it's clear that
a lot of work has gone into trying to
get this development right
um it looks high quality to me and i i
have every confidence that where it to
be delivered it would be high quality
um i think one concern that i do have
however and
councillor duffield spoke to this quite
at length during her representation
is around um the car parking advice that
we've received
and the report i have to say is
extremely robust and i think it does a
really good job
of demonstrating that on this sort of
application it is about
having to weigh up the balance of pros
and cons of development and i think that
the report's really
honest about that and it really comes
through but i have to say i
was a little bit concerned around
paragraph 282
where it is quite clear that the lha do
have some concerns around the parking
provision and i made a point of looking
at
um the consultation document
provided by ms hendren i think um from
amy
and really i think what comes through is
that we haven't found a way to sort of
um resolve the the concerns that have
been raised by the lha
i i absolutely accept that you know this
site
it's very well serviced by public
transport with metrolink
and within the bus routes and i also
accept that it's
you know really somebody my age that's
walking distance into town or jolton
or into stratford uh if you if you want
it to be
but i think that the lha were quite
clear that they have concerns
and i just have a hesitation about sort
of approving
the development without those concerns
having been more
robustly addressed i think um and then
the final sort of point i did want to
make is that
and i think councilor hartley spoke to
this as well
um i agree that you know
376 i think it is it really does a good
job of demonstrating the benefits that
this scheme
um would deliver but what i would say is
i think the proceeding paragraph 374 and
375 perhaps
don't fully um
speak to the the concerns around the
adverse impacts
um and you know i think that that was
driven home to me when
uh we received the representations from
ward councillors and from this o'connor
so i think i'm
cautiously in favor of this development
but i do have some reservations
emilio is hoping to hear from other
members to see what see what their
thinking is as well
um i know that others have indicated so
with that
i i will hold uh judgement just yet but
as i say cautiously optimistic
cautiously in favor um but i i
i will listen to others have to say and
reflect on that thank you jeff
thank you councillor williams um before
i bring in council accordingly
he's going to speak uh soon um
can you ask mr evanson just just to sum
up if you can
the view of the lha around this
application mr evanson are you there
i am yes counselor apologies
um yes i mean in terms of the level of
parking as
we we did have some reservations but as
we've done with
oh suggestion for the the earlier side
to that tonight about bnq
and the one we did last month with
regards to the kellogg site
in in terms of protecting the highway
and we're reasonably comfortable whilst
we're concerned about the level of
parking and whether or not it would be
realistic and whether it will be
successful
then the mitigation we've proposed
and i believe the applicants accepted
according to the report
whereby we can address any shortcomings
with introductions of additional parking
restrictions
go some way to addressing our concerns
okay um around traffic movement
on match days how how what's the lhas
view
on there with no football at the moment
obviously but when
when football starts up again on a
saturday and we've got saturday traffic
do you have any concerns around that in
in
in terms of the actual traffic itself or
the actual
parking concerns yeah well both if you
like the
physically moving around old trafford
and
you know trafford bar and close to the
football ground and park you know lots
of fans
park down there on a on a match day
don't they they do yes
and obviously there's match day parking
restrictions in that location
and as part of those of any tros which
got amended then that would have to be
taken
into consideration where the the
problems would be i think it
deludes to that the local residents
wouldn't actually be um wouldn't be able
to get
a pass for for those at some of those
areas locally
so we would have to take on board when
we do consider what
changes do come forward the mix of the
res
current residential issues match day
parking and any
fall out for the the actual development
should the development not be
successful in terms of restricting or
dissuading people from car ownership
yeah
um simple terms if people start parking
down on lime grove and on the other
streets nearby
the the applicant is providing funds to
to to install tros in those areas to
protect those residents
in that they've agreed to take on board
undertaking surveys in and around those
areas you just mentioned
correct yes yeah okay
um all right i'm advice councillor kerry
he's going to speak to us now councillor
carey
uh thank you chairman uh i will be uh
proposing to
um support the office recommendation
tonight
uh i think the balance has just about
been met as far as i can see
um nothing's ever perfect uh i want to
applaud the speakers the two councillors
and i think the resident's name i'm
sorry i think was mrs o'connor or miss
o'connor
yes and
i applaud them for trying to get this
thing to be perfect
but we're in a situation at the moment
which makes that very very difficult
and so i will be proposing that we do
support this
and just another point again on
education and 500 000 pounds is really
welcome for the primary school provision
but
that's nothing and the lab in my school
when i had it redeveloped cost
97 000 for one classroom so i'm not sure
what that's going to go towards
it's 367 units we do need an education
plan
um one of the councillors mentioned
about this development not having much
support for
sports i think or green space and
we've had multiple opportunities in the
last few years as a council to support
the development of sporting facilities
with turn moss
and with the recent one in sale and we
seem to have not supported them
so i will be proposing that we um grant
this application tonight
thank you chairman thank you councillor
carey council accordingly
thank you chair um yeah i'd be happy to
second
counselor carey if that's where the way
we're going
it is a balanced decision and i was
really impressed
like everybody else with the the quality
of the speakers
um i'm conscious that we've missed the
point
that um there is quite a lot of high
rise down the seymour grove corridor
it does exist and a lot of it is office
to resi
and it does occur to me that
this is much higher quality than any of
those
office-to-resi i'm not totally in favor
of
high-rise residential but it exists and
it's suitable for some people and
if it's going to happen i'd much prefer
it to be of this quality
than some of the office to resist we've
had on seymour grove corridor
in trafford bar uh warrick road as well
um it would so it
is quite a high bar that's been set and
i do as well as praising the um
speakers i'd also praise uh traffic
planning staff on this
because it is quite significant it's not
just about a
loss of an extra uh floor on this i
think they've worked really hard with
the developer
to develop a really good scheme i mean
it was originally going to have gates
and
uh i would be deadly opposed to that and
so we have made progress with the
developer i think
i think in in balance it it would be
hard
for me to find reasons that planning
reasons to refuse it
if i'm honest given the report given
everything else
there was one question i did ask sarah
this afternoon in fact
um it was a connection with the um
being cusack with the b q report
included um spacing standards within the
individual
houses so the quality of the housing
that for people that lived there
and the reply came back that actually we
didn't need to put that because it
wasn't
in the um area action plan
uh this block is not in the area of
action plan whereas b and q
was and so we had to stick we we had to
give
the the qual um spacing standards for
the bing queue site
but having said that the quality the
spacing standards within this site
were better than the national standards
and really good
and that was important to me um so we're
delivering a good quality project
compared to as i say a lot of office to
resi that we're unable to
often to have any planning impacts at
all
because it's permitted so on balance i
really do support this
um and i i accept it nothing's perfect
but i'd struggle to find reason to
refuse
yeah thank you chair thank you council
accordingly councillor jerome
thank you chair i'm i'm going to um
support councillor
carey and councillor accordingly um
on this i think they're
i like their arguments and i'm not going
to repeat to too many of them really
but um i just wanted to say when i
visited the site
you couldn't see a more perfect
brownfield site
for development it's not surrounded by
urban streets
it's actually you know stands stands
alone
and it it really is ripe develop
relevant it's perfectly located next to
transport facilities
and if if you actually look at the
application it is a very good one
um it's got a good proportion of family
free bed homes and two beds
and way above the recommended um
affordable housing mix as well um
the affordable housing also meets the 10
requirement
which um which i think is good um i
think maybe that requirement should be
higher but that's not the
applicant's fault um
and i i think it's really really good
that on this brownfield site the
landscaping
is so well thought through um 152 native
trees which which is good to see you
know developers don't always put native
trees in
so that that's a a good thing to see on
my behalf
um and of course there will be problems
with the car parking
shortfall and i think that could cause
problems and it
is a worry and and i i would like to
have seen a car sharing scheme here
possibly
um and i wonder whether that that could
have been thought about
an ev car sharing scheme for residents
which could have taken
some of the impact away from that but if
you look at the cycling facilities
they are very good it's i think it's one
for one
um so and they're looking at i believe
cycling secure units as well
so i'm quite happy with that so i think
that that that's pretty good
so i i think um our planning team have
done a good job on this it's a good
application
and i don't think i'll have too much
problem in in supporting it because
you know we have got a housing need in
this borough we do need to meet it
and i i think this is the perfect site
for it and this
overall is a good application so i will
be supporting it
thanks jeff thank you councillor jerome
um
we've had been moved and seconded that
we grant this application i'm going to
go to the vote
councillor williams how would you like
to vote
uh vote to grant in line with officer
recommendation thank
thank you councillor carey
vote to grant please chairman very much
councillor stennett i don't think he's
he's
still at uh scrutiny councillor holden
i'll just do it now it's very very short
and there's that i i feel like there
there are
pros and cons if you will with it with
with the application
and i think but i i like the i mean
i need to can i just stop you there
we'll have to stop the vote if you need
to speak
if you want to continue speaking i just
have to stop stop the vote and start
again i can't
uh have a you're making a representation
in
the middle of the voting apologies i've
missed you but if you want to speak
you'll have to go back to the voting at
the beginning okay so you go ahead
council of minnesota
and put forward your views okay okay
thank you
um yeah the there there there's a couple
of
bits that i wasn't um
so where where it had about the the um
size that there were concerns about the
sizing of the
development and i just wanted to know
whether the like we had the light
um sort of study as it were on the
previous
you know one of the previous ones and
i'm wondering whether that was done
on this that was a question and okay
i will ask miss laws to comment uh
council image but
uh i don't think we're so close to
residents um properties that that would
be affected but um
miss lowe's would you like to comment
it's more so it's more for the residents
that would be
in these properties does that make sense
yeah yeah it's about the light impact to
them
and what they would yeah yeah that's
fine miss lowe's could you comment on
that
and thank you yes and the detailed
daylight sunlight report
will be application and that is detailed
extensively within the officer report
and what it says is that there will be
some minor shortfalls on i think five
units in total
but overall well the rest of the units
would receive
high standards of earthquake license and
life and overall it would meet the um
supplements guidance so
we're happy with the levels of the life
for the residential
development okay thank you that thank
you we can go to vote now thanks
oh thank you right we'll go back to the
beginning councilor williams
a vote to approve in line with us a
recommendation thank you
thank you thank you castle williams
councillor carey
councilman carey
so i lost i lost i pressed the wrong
button i vote to grant please sorry
thank you councillor kerry councillor
stennis not with us councillor holden
he will vote
a vote to grant thank you thank you
councillor rigby's
sent his apologies councillor procter
uh difficult decision but i'm
overall i'm voting against the up across
the recommendation to grant
okay thank you councillor procter
councillor hartley
actually yeah i mean i agree finally
balanced i think uh
a lot of my concerns have probably been
addressed so i'm going to vote uh
my money to grant to agree with the
recommendation you
uh councillor jerome
i'm going to support officer
recommendation you
councillor dr barclay
hi chairman i came in just as this has
started so i
can't vote i'm afraid thank you for
advising me of that counselor dr barclay
council accordingly
uh thank you and i'll be voting to grant
that's one two three four five six seven
eight volts in favor and one vote
against so the application has been
granted thank you everybody
thank you chairman just as a point of
clarification that's mind to ground with
subject to
the 106 and the like yeah yeah that's
money yeah
okay it's been granted mine in
accordance with the recommendation yeah
and according to the recommendation
for our 106 agreement to be agreed yes
and otherwise
yeah okay yeah the application has been
agreed thank you miss lowes
for your work on this and thanks to the
to all the speakers for their
contributions to this item
thank you chair um we're going to go to
page 109 that's four woodlands
and davey hume
so that's um yeah page 109
four woodlands road and we have speakers
for and against this item
and i'll just get my notes
do we have mr bean
hello good evening hello mr bean yeah
good afternoon mr bean you have three
minutes to speak against this item thank
you
uh introduction chairman chairman
um that's mr day he's going to give us
an introduction to this sorry apologies
mr bean apologies for that
uh thank you chairman um i think uh mrs
coley is just going to
um put the uh slideshow onto the screen
i am yes bear with me um
i'm very happy about it
one sec
sorry it's looking around all over the
place
yep okay um
this application uh has been called in
through the committee by councillor win
stanley
um on the grounds that it would result
in loss of light
and loss of privacy to the neighbouring
property at number five
woodland um the application property
number four woodland
is a two-story detached property located
on a small private road
accessed from old cross bank the
application is retrospective and
proposes to very condition
who the approved plans condition and
three
the materials condition of planning
permission 95935
hha 18 the extension has not been built
in accordance with the previously
approved plans
the alterations are listed in full in
the committee report
but in summary they include
changes to the footprint which includes
both additions and reductions in the
approved footprint
changes in height certain aspects most
notably
on the southern side of the prison side
extension
um going just
through the internal layout and
elevation details
including construction design and
proportions and changes in materials
with the windows and doors
to engrave upvc i'll just point out on
that
um the extension on the left hand side
there on the front elevation is where
it's been raised
in height adjacent to number five
woodland
representations have been received from
four neighbouring properties
two objecting to the proposals and two
confirming no objections
whilst it is considered that the changes
have resulted in some reduction in the
design quality of the development
officers consider that the revised
scheme would not have an unacceptable
impact on the visual appearance and
character of the street scene
and the surrounding area
but yeah you can see on on these slides
the um
photographs of the scheme has built um
the amended scheme has resulted in some
limited additional impact in relation to
neighbouring properties
however it's considered that subject to
appropriate conditions
it would not have an unacceptable impact
on the residential immunity of
neighboring dwellings
proposed alterations to the extension
and subject conditions are considered to
be acceptable in accordance with
policy l7 the sbd4 guidelines
and the mppf and it's therefore
recommended that the application should
be approved
subject conditions
thank you mr day um
mr bean would you like to come back to
us
yes thank you mr bean thank you for your
patience
i trust my uh statement with the
pictures yeah
we've got your state as well if you'd
like to uh to speak now
thank you okay thank you very much
committee members i do not have time to
reiterate the points made in the
numerous pieces of correspondence that
have been submitted over the last two
and a half years
against this development by residents of
one three and five woodlands
we trust all our correspondence has been
read and noted there are 12 residents in
the woodlands where they're
about their lives massively disrupted
during the 20 months
encountering of construction work you're
out of hours working and noise dust
pollution
excessive vertical traffic and speed
damage to the road and impact on
drainage
see the photograph below the owners of
four woodlands who we all feel have
shown no consideration to other
residents throughout have moved out
since the start of construction
luxury the rest of us do not have our
joint frustration is that the building
has not been built in line with approved
plans
especially in terms of its overall
height what's negatively affecting the
woodlands as a whole this has had a
particular impact on five woodlands in
terms of lots of light and privacy
which the other residents have allowed
me to focus on giving time constraints
it undermines the integrity of the
planning process that approved plans are
not complied with
we believe that traffic councils are
duty to protect the interests of
residents who have been subject to
deliberate manipulation of the planning
process
by commercial planning consultants this
is not a case of
mistakes resulting in unapproved changes
this is willful non-compliance with
approved plans
if everybody were to take this attitude
it would make a complete mockery of the
whole planning process
as you'll see from the chronology of
correspondence it is our letters showing
the repeated inaccuracies in the
consultant's plans that prompted the
multiple revisions
such consultants do not make repeating
mistakes by accident
loss of light there is no mention of a
side extension next to five the
woodlands and the approved plans
this construction is in contravention of
guidance contained within the original
plane application
additionally the approved plans state
that the proposed development will be
approximately six meters
from the share boundary with number five
the planning officer's report states
that this side extension is 2.2 meters
from our property
it is less than the picture below this
unapproved side extension built upwards
by nearly two meters clearly affects the
light offered
by two windows in our living room which
faced this expansive brick
how can this be built without any
consultation or consequence
planning officer's report states that
the changes have made this side
extension more dominant
however it still remains subservient to
the main house how could it not be the
house has been extended to twice its
original size
it should be judged for its impact on
five woodlands what's for privacy
there are now two skylight windows offer
the ability to look directly into the
back garden of our property that we're
not on the approved plan
put simply prior to this work we were
not overlooked from to all woodlands
now we are conclusion i'd like to thank
the committee for allowing me to speak
on behalf of the residents of the
woodlands
the planning officers report states the
changes to the external appearance would
have a limited visual impact within the
wider area
given the secluded and private setting
of the property it is the impact on
those who live in the close that matters
this property does not respect the
established character and form of
development in the surrounding area
whilst words can be interpreted in
different ways the most powerful
demonstration to the
committee of how badly let down we all
feel is shown by the photograph below
willful manipulation the planning
process particularly regarding the
building's unapproved
increased height has resulted in this
overbearing property
a sad indictment these are our family
homes
and everyday lives been affected
that's the end of the statement thank
you mr bean
um before i bring in the speaker in
favor of the application do we have mr
councillor stanley's statement
we do chairman yes um would you like to
read
it i will read that out um thank you
thank you to members for listening to
this written representation
i did call this in for the reasons shown
in the report i
would result in loss of light and loss
of privacy to number five woodlands
but there are other reasons for a very
detailed consideration of this
application
as the officer's report says woodlands
is a small road
where the more the narrow access road
and trees contribute to the impression
of a secluded and private area
all of us who carried out our site visit
can certainly attest to this
and the development of four woodlands
does substantially change this overall
impression of the road
it does have an over-dominant aspect it
also impinges on the immunity of
neighbours by reasons of design and
scale
as acknowledged in the office's report
the current build among other things
has resulted in the loss of a number of
features which were considered to
enhance the approved scheme
such as the window designing
configuration as built
it has increased the east heights of the
site lead to extension
which has resulted in a differing roof
profile these issues in themselves
should give members pause for thought
but there are other issues
concerning the level of confidence now
held by the residents of the overall
planning process
members will have picked up on the fact
that this current application seeks
permission retrospectively
for work which goes beyond the scope of
the previous past plans
the view of the office's report is that
these variations are acceptable
local residents disagree just as
importantly
many of these variations have been
completed even though permission has not
been granted
this has understandably caused some
consternation with local residents
to quote from one piece of
correspondence you will no doubt have
gathered our frustration at the process
at the end of the day we want to ensure
that a fair and compliant process has
been followed
i really do struggle to see how this
remodeled property can be said to not
overly dominate the close
never mind the unapproved changes that
impact our property
therefore my request today is for the
committee to turn down this current
application
to allow our filing officer's time to
work with the applicant and local
residents
to arrive at a mutually acceptable
solution and so also very publicly
demonstrate
what we on the committee already know
that residents can have faith in the
funding process thank you that ends the
statement
thank you miss coley do we have mr
hallett mr hallett
uh yes hello hello mr hallett yes you
have three minutes mr hallett
thank you good afternoon my name is tom
hallett uh acting on behalf of the
applicants mr and mrs patel
uh 30 likes to plan thank finding
officer for her report
and approach to with the application
proposals which has enabled
the matters leading to the
recommendation performing today
as noted in your report permission to
conditions
attached to the content the amendment
sort simply reflect my chance my
client's aspirations at creating a home
for his family in a part of the world
that they have close ties to
considering the effect of the changes on
the design and appearance of the area
we wish to highlight the site is
situated in a small culvert sack where
each property varies significantly in
scale form and design the woodlands is
private and very secluded in nature
giving it surrounding mature tree cover
nature of the changes to the overall
scheme are considered modest
and principally the side lean to
extension continues to remain
subservient
as confirmed by officers the overall
scale and proportions of the extensions
are similar to that previously approved
when assessed against adopted policy and
national guidance they are acceptable
in terms of design and visual immunity
furthermore changes to the external
appearance would have a very limited
visual impact on the wider area because
of the private setting of the property
with regards to residential immunity we
understand the neighbor's rate
learned by reason of overshadowing and
overlooking specifically
changes to the lean to the designer
amendments in this regard
are fully compliant with adopted
guidance they're proportionate and
complementary in height and width
to the size of the original dwelling and
will not result in undue loss of light
or present
as with previous approval the rear
projection would also not result in any
unacceptable overbearing or
overshadowing impact
property continues to be over 21 meters
from the boundary number one
and the distance from the damage to the
shared boundaries have increased by
approximately a meter
it's therefore clear that the
neighboring properties of women be
harmed
with development having regard to life
and scaling form there remains no
implications for any other matters
provision relating to access power
parking and tree protection all remains
as previously approved
conclude proposal is a design scaling
style that is appropriate to the context
of the development
alterations to the extension are
considered to be acceptable competitive
positions
from adaptive policy and guidance thank
you for your time
thank you mr hallett um you're lying
with disappearing for a time mr heller
and then you were coming back in to us
um but there we go that's fine we've
we've heard what you've had to say
um any members wishing to speak to this
item
okay well i'll just just open the
discussion if i may and ask mr day
mr dave the the changes that have been
made
to the property the uh the uh the
changes that were
being asked to approve today are they
com policy compliant
yeah and in terms of um impact on
residential immunity
um there will be policy compliance
subject to
um additional conditions recommended in
the report regarding
obscure glazing windows being re-flights
being fixed or
with restricted opening mechanisms um
obviously in terms of
the projection of the extension at the
um southern side adjacent to number five
woodlands that is politic
compliant in terms of our spd4
um obviously in in terms of
um why
there's perhaps a more subjective
assessment
to be made in relation to that but we
believe that it is party compliant in
terms of its
um uh design appearance and impact on
the
visual appearance of the area okay so
there's no standout issues that tell us
that the the application is not policy
complaint
that's what we're saying yes okay
okay thanks for that um councillor
hartley you'd like to speak
i mean i think what mr day has just said
is is is probably the
key point really that if it's that it
was no policy compliant
um i think i think we probably have
difficulty in refusing but
having said that the reason i wanted to
speak was to was to agree with
much of what um mr bean the
the neighboring resident said that
the fact this application is being made
does does concern me greatly i i
appreciate that you know retrospective
applications can be made and that's part
of the planning
process but it does feel as though you
know an application has been made
approval's been given
and then the applicants just proceeded
to to build something
different so it it does seem to ride you
know roughshod
over um the planning approval process
and
and that does and that does concern me
and and the changes
are numerous you can you can see that
from the uh
the summary of the of the alterations
which is on page 109 and 110 you know
started to read that and
it reads almost like a a completely
different application
um and and so that it really does
concern me
the way the applicant has gone about
this and uh
i hesitate to an extent in in saying
this but uh but i do think
that it's a it's a really um
it's a really unhelpful and unappealing
way
to go about engaging with the planning
process which which is there to
protect the immunity of residents and to
protect the the character of
of uh you know of areas within within
trafford
i think the difficulty probably that
we've got is
the the altered scheme is policy
compliant so that suggests if d
if the applicant had had had made the
correct application what they actually
have ended up building then
then that would have been uh approved
i'm not i'm not sure i'm not sure it is
that straightforward because
the the sort of resolution that's
suggested and i applaud
you know the the planning team for
trying to come to a resolution
through appropriate conditions but those
conditions are unusual to say that
you know roof flights that have already
been incorporated are
obscured laced and are sealed shut so
they can't be opened i don't know if we
would
if we would normally sort of accept roof
lights in an application in in that way
and um
and i suppose the enforcement of those
conditions you know concerns me
who's going to monitor whether those
reflex can be opened and an impact on
the immunity of
of of neighboring residents so
it's with some regret i think that you
know that
the alternative uh to to granting this i
suppose if we refuse will be that
um will be that the applicant then has
to start pulling down bits of the
property um
which would cause you know more
disruption to residents
you know uh prolonged the building works
that are going on there
so i think at the moment uh you know
unless i can be persuaded otherwise i'm
probably
you know with some regret minded to
agree with the officer recommendation
but i do think it's a very
unsatisfactory sort of uh timeline of
events that has occurred
thank you chair thank you councillor
hartley councillor minis
i don't have to agree agree entirely
with council uh hartley there
um i think it's really it sets a bad
feeling
um amongst and to to you know between
neighbors
um whenever the residents uh of of the
of the of the application have come back
to the home
and the way the way in which it's been
done that you've applied for one thing
and then built a different thing
and now we're trying to come up with
some sort of in-betweeny solution
um with like as he said with the
obscured sealed
uh um you know uh skylights as it were
and i think it guesses i mean the crux
is as
uh mr stay said it was it's you know
it's it's compliant so
i guess we can't although may not like
it
as it were may have to approve um
but i i i i can't say that this is a way
that should
have ever been recommended to any
resident uh wishing to
extend their house because you now um
you know you live with your neighbors
and you should always have good
trying to have good relations with your
neighbors and when you go through an um
extension application i would hope that
people
actually spoke to their neighbors uh
before they even put the application in
to you know let their neighbors know
because to find out through the council
and then they've gone and
built something else it's not a way to
go is it really
and but yeah i think begrudgingly i'll
be uh
approving it looks like thank you
councilman i think you spoke for us all
there councillor jerome
i just wanted to thank councillor
hartley for
speaking so well i think you've
articulated um
many of the points i would have liked to
have made but you've made them so well
so i just wanted to say thank you and i
think many of the
committee will probably feel the same so
thank you chair
thank you councillor jerome uh we'll go
to the vote it's been
well i don't think it has actually been
moved but some would like to move a
second that we grant this
councillor jerome would you like to move
that we grant this
well i'll propose that we grant this
then just to to move things to head i'll
propose that we grant this application
in the fashion that council ministers
described um did anybody like to second
that
happy just like in that chat second
thank you council williams
council williams how would you like to
vote um
a proving line of office of
recommendation thank you
thank you very much councillor carey
vote to grant please chairman
thank you councillor stan it's not with
us councillor holden
sadly i wish you have stayed okay
thank you councillor minis
um begrudgingly um in favor
thank you council minis councillor rugby
sent his apologies councillor proctor
um thank you very much
councillor hartley very similar mind uh
because it's policy compliant
i'll vote in accordance with the officer
recommendation
but very unhappily i have to say thank
you
councillor jerome
thank you councillor dr barclay hi chair
i support the officer's recommendation
to grant thank you council accordingly
support the officer's recommendation
thank you and i'll be supporting the
officer's recommendation to ground
that's one two three four five seven
eight nine votes
in favor of the application and one
against or one abstention i should say
abduce has been granted thank you
everybody for your contributions
um okay we've got a 6 30 finish tonight
it's now
10 past six i'm going to go to
application
on the application on page 91 that's 165
a
marsman road 165 a maslin road
and do we have
do you have mr mcvean with us this
evening
mr mcvean
sure i'm just going to do an
introduction first oh sorry
sorry um miss milner yes your
instruction please miss milner
okay i just think i'm getting a bit
carried away trying to speed us along
apologies for that
okay um so this is the the presentation
i'll be as quick as possible to share so
the um application for you relates to uh
an existing five big dwelling accessed
off marsden's road this is marsden's
road the access is down the middle
and the application proposes to extend
remodel and subdivide the existing
property to form
two five-bed semi-detached dwellings and
the physical alterations include
raising the height of the property and
by 1.2 meters
and extensions to the front side and
rear with two dormers on the rear roof
slope
um received
that is why it's before you and concerns
from local residents that the proposal
will
result in a over development of the site
and a cramped form of development
that will cause disturbance to
surrounding residents during
construction
and once occupied and also would
negatively impact on the character of
the area due to the design
and amenity of surrounding residents as
detailed within your report
and this is the existing property as you
can see
and then this is the proposal so
extensions to the front
side and rear and raising of the ridge
height and some photographs here so this
is the access road down
you see that the property in the middle
and the extensions will be as i said
front of the property to the north the
south and the side
and objections have been received from
surrounding
neighbours um whilst we
do fully appreciate the concerns of
local residents
and and detailed that within the office
report as this will provide an
additional dwelling and additional
family dwelling
and as is considered to be an
appropriate design and scale for the
site
and has sufficient car parking as well
as amenity space
officers do consider that subject to the
conditions as outlined in the officer
report
we can recommend approval thank you
thank you miss milner um mr mcvean are
are you there
i am yes hello and you have
three minutes to put forward your your
your views mr mcvean thank you very much
thank you
uh my name is rory mcveigh i'm an
immediate neighbour living at 167
marsden road
i wish to register my strong objection
and that of my neighbours
to the proposed development in addition
i wish to raise a specific concern on
behalf of mr j
s wilson living at three grey state
avenue
the application does give us a number of
concerns and our views are well
documented and the officers just
mentioned a number of them but if i can
summarize we're concerned about
over development it's simply too big for
the modest plot
it's almost doubling in size with a 40
increase this will result in the loss of
privacy
and overlooking of residents that
surround it
the loss of light by raising the ridge
significantly will reduce
the amount of light reaching neighbors
gardens
impact on trees there'll be a loss of a
significant
and mature tree which will result in the
loss
of amenity there'll be impact on parking
the provision
is too small for the number of vehicles
and and the access
from marsden road is just simply too
narrow
there'll be a problem with noise both
during construction and when in use
because it's entirely
surrounded by gardens it will have an
overbearing negative
impact on residents js wilson who
lives at number three grace stake is
also an immediate neighbor
has raised an issue about privacy
distances and the fact that as stated
they are incorrect in the agenda paper
received at 3
20 today officers now concede that the
privacy distances
fall short by two meters
these privacy distance are surely not
for interpretation
or adjustment and must be adhered to for
the public to have any faith
in the planning system we feel that this
does not comply
with trafford's sdp 4 which was adopted
in 2012
item 2.15 overlooking and loss of
privacy
the other issue that was picked up in
the additional information agenda today
is the removal of a mature tree
number t11 for reasons that it drops
leaves on neighbours garages
i don't believe and we don't believe
that seasonal embarrassment should be
a justifiable reason for its removal we
need to protect
these valuable established landscape
features and it simply suggests to us
that
the site is just too small to support
this size of development
so in conclusion we respectfully request
that the application be refused on the
ground the development constitutes
over development by virtue of scale
amassing loss of light
impact on trees negative impact on
transport
transport and parking negative impact of
noise
and the fact that privacy distances have
not been met
thank you thank you mr mcvean
um any members wishing to speak to this
item
yeah um i'm just wondering
he's raised two points around um
i think his terminology was officers now
can see previous distances
are in effect breached and he's also
raised
an objection on the basis of the tree
removal i don't know if
anybody from planning can sort of just
provide a bit of a response
um to the two points he's made there yes
i'm happy to so firstly on the
issue of the privacy distances this is
guidance this is in our supported
planning document
and is guidance we do seek to stick to
that guidance
but it's a case-by-case basis now
the distance we have several different
um privacy distances
so one of them is from the rear and
properties to the to kind of the back
garden
and at first floor and the dormers this
this
is fully compliant and is pretty much on
the mark at ground floor to the rear of
the property and that is in relation to
the boundary with
uh three grey stone and whilst
i think it falls short by two meters
it's 25 meters rather than 27
we are still fully confident that while
there may be
some slight impact that the provision of
an additional family
house would override any negative impact
and
we are still confident that a separation
distance of 25 meters is satisfactory
and would not
result in harmful impacts on amenity in
regards
to the the loss of the tree there are a
total of three trees
um to be removed um as part of the
proposal there was a tree report
and it was recommended in that report
that the tree probably is is
should be removed and it wasn't a good
specimen and but it wasn't um advocated
at the start of the application however
free discussions with neighbours
um and our tree officer it was supported
that this tree should you know it could
be removed
and it's better to replace it with a
better quality specimen that could
could live on for a high number of years
then retain a low quality specimen that
might
and deteriorate um over the coming years
so
we have no objection to the loss of that
tree we we didn't have an
objection and that has been checked with
our agriculturalists so
on both points we are we are satisfied
um sorry
for her response to that i'm just
wondering
by way of mitigating for the loss of a
tree
would that come under 0.8
prior to the above construction where
it's a scheme for biodiversity
enhancements would would that be
a condition that would allow for almost
like a
replacement i'm just thinking yeah we
have a landscaping condition
so the biodiversity condition is related
all about species on site and provision
of kind of
black boxes bed boxes and the like um
but
the edition four is a landscaping
condition and that can
to provide new trees and then we've also
got
condition five which series to protect
all remaining trees right
so yes we do have a suitable condition
thank you for that response thank you
chad thank you councilor williams
councillor jerome you'd like to comment
thanks um i live in timberley and i've
kind of lived there for the last 10
years and i've seen
over that time the bats kind of
completely disappear
um from from the area you see them
fluttering about all the time
and i don't know whether that's due to
kind of some of the extensions that have
gone on in the area or whether it's just
due to kind of insect loss or other
other reasons
but i've noticed um in in the report at
number
point 50 it does say that this is the
bat
assessments have been done with in best
practice but i thought
looking at the back conservation trust
guidance it's more kind of standard
practice or minimum practice the
emergence surveys that have been done um
and i've noticed in a another
application
where um where there's been similar
evidence of of bats in the area um
and i know there's no roots proven in in
this house
in a other application it did say that
the
the roof should be designed to be
friendly to bats but also
that they should think about bat boxes
and the like
and i couldn't see any of that in the
conditions so i just wondered if
the planning team had doing anything on
that front
miss milner yes councillor drone that is
the condition eight that i
i referenced to councillor williams the
biodiversity condition so
it just say prior to any above ground
constriction a scheme for biodiversity
enhancement as the
other site should be submitted and
approved in writing and i would
specifically note that on this site
we did previously refuse the scheme
because of inadequate and bat surveys
and so this application has been
resubmitted with updated and higher
quality surveys that have been
verified and approved by greater
manchester ecology unit
and on the back of that we have
condition 8.
thanks sir miss milner uh i'd just like
to say the back conservation trust
they've taken their emergency surveys
from 7.3 the table 7.3 in the back
conservation trust guidance which is
just it says a minimum level
but that does seem to be standard
practice um
and so is acceptable but if you go down
in the back conservation trust's
guidance and to go to their table at 8.3
it does recommend kind of monthly
surveys between april and october
um which you know what i'd like to see
um but obviously what's been done is
acceptable so i just thought i'd make
that point
thank you councillor jerome any other
members wishing to speak
um can i say um while you're thinking
about that i went to view the site on
sunday
uh i got quite near to it i went into
the uh
to the housing development next door and
um
i for me i looked and and it looked to
be a house in
in a large setting and um
you know neighbors are close by but
i didn't i really didn't feel the um the
the changes that i propose would would
be so significant to affect those
neighbors and
um and it's a beautiful setting for a
property
um but you know i i i look round the
front
as i said i went next door and went into
a a nursery
just down marslin road liquor where i
went to their backyard
their gates were open i went in the back
of there and viewed from there i could
see over the fence
and again when i when i when i saw that
sort of um
saw the cold face if you like the
distances involved i
i didn't think anything that's proposed
today would have such a
such a significant on the residents that
um that weren't refusing i hear what mr
mcvean said and
he's clearly unhappy but but for me the
application is okay
but i'm happy to take other members
comments if anybody else would like to
speak
uh i don't think anybody anybody else
wants to speak
um well i actually i'll propose that we
grant this application
um i don't have any concerns about it to
be frank so
i propose that we grant it would anybody
like to second my proposal
to grant this application
we will need a seconder our second chair
your secondary council hartley thank you
so it's been proposed by council of
world seconded by
councillor harvey that would grant this
application um
i'll go to the vote councillor williams
how would you like to vote
rancher in line with office of
recommendation thank you recommendation
thank you councillor carey how would you
like to vote i vote to grant please
chairman thank you very much councillor
holden
mr grant thank you councillor minis
um i'll vote to grant thank you thank
you
uh councillor procter
thank you council procter council
harpley thank you vote grant
uh chair thank you thank you councillor
jerome
thanks john did you say grant counselled
your own
yes yeah sorry thank you council for dr
barclay support the officer's
recommendation to grant chairman
thank you councillor dr barclay council
accordingly
grants chair thank you and i'll be
voting for grant
uh that's unanimous um everybody's
voting in favor granting applications is
granted
thank you everybody for your
contributions it's 6 25
and we have a 6 30 finish um
this evening i'm just looking for advice
from
officers if if we're happy to go into
another item
we may overrun by some minutes
we may start another one um as long as
you started the
the next item before 6 30 then that's
fine
that's fine okay so we'll go to
um 39 to 42 ingleby court that's 130
of your um of your agenda papers
and we have an introduction from miss
milner 39 to 42
in grubby courts miss milner
are you there miss milner
yes sorry i'm just having problems
sharing the presentation
could one of the offices
right right so the application for you
relates to
a block um a two-story block of flats
39-42 ingolby court
and the application proposes to amend
the roof design from a pitch roof to a
mansard roof
to accommodate one additional flat
the application um also has
five dormers on the front elevation and
whilst the overall height of the
building
will not change there will be a change
in the the massing of the roof
um in the mansard style we have received
um
a number of objections from luke wasn't
so this this is the
existing um existing elevations on the
right
and the proposed on the left and in
addition
they changed the roof they are looking
to make some cello general changes to
the elevation
including the pulp front porch so we
have received um
quite significant objection from local
residents and
ways to concern about the impact on
their amenity and through the rate
design and in terms of loss of light
and being overbearing this sense about
parking
there also also a number of concerns
about and the impact on the construction
process
and the people that currently live in
the property
there are a number of consents that are
outlined um in regards to
um ownership however that is a separate
matter we are looking at design and
amenity
and whilst officers do fully understand
the concerns
um of local residents specifically those
living in the existing
um block of flats would you consider
that on balance the proposed design
um would be acceptable given that it
does provide an additional unit
and i would also note that whilst the
extension covers the whole roof
only one side of the uh the converted
roof would accommodate a
residential unit the other half would be
for storage and that is a condition of
the permission
so subject to the conditions as outlined
in the opposite report including the
additional
information report we do recommend
approval thank you chair
thank you miss milner um we have a
statement from mr earnshaw speaking
against the application
yes i'll be reading that out chairman
you're reading it out mrs call it yes it
the uh there's been a slight change in
in the fact that this statement
is now on behalf of the leaseholders so
not just mr earnshaw
okay so the statement reason as follows
the proposal suggested first and
foremost does not represent a
sustainable development as a basic
premise
the building regulations elements in
particular structure fire separation
secondary means of escape fire noise
insulation between floors etc all need
to be achieved by means of carrying out
construction work
around over and under the ceilings of
current apartments
this will severely impact the residents
living there currently and will not be
allowed by the tenants or leaseholders
without achieving these basic health and
safety standards the development will
not be considered a safe and habitable
structure
as a result the proposal would not be
sustainable which is directly a planning
matter this committee must consider
leaseholders are entitled to quiet
enjoyment of their properties
the additional noise of having more
residents in the block would be
substantial
the noise of building on this
development will also have a drastic
effect on the residents in their lives
scaffolding around the building would
lead to loss of light
in addition to the above the
leaseholders and neighbors are shocked
and upset that planning
officers have turned a blind eye to the
fact that this is clearly an over
development of the site
the additional accommodation is clearly
one too many in the building
it makes the building an incongruous
three-story structure not in keeping
with the area and clearly a deviation
from national polling policy framework
the design of the roof and elevations
are of poor quality and consistent with
the local context
the car parking space proposed has been
shoehorned into an area not meant to its
purpose
and will constrict access to existing
spaces leading to aggravation between
residents which should be weighed as a
design security problem
there's only currently enough parking
space for the current residence
access to garages is essentially will be
compromised
particularly in time when homes are your
only sale
safe haven as more and more people
staying indoors and using their immunity
spaces for recreation
this proposal also causes a loss of
precious outdoor immunity space for
current residents
the building is made higher there will
be lots of light to the garden and will
significantly affect the
surrounding properties access the light
all flats were purchased on the premise
at the areas of buying a property that
was part of a small community of four
flats
the first four flats were purchased as
top four properties within the building
and any building the considerably can
change the original design of the
function of the building
we urge traffic councils to put the
residents of trafford before the profits
of property development
to sum up we strongly urge that these
matters be taken into account this
application being
rejected on the grounds of being
unsustainable development
over development of the site design not
in keeping with the local area
in practicable car parking design and
loss of remaining tea to existing
residents
and that's the end of the statement
thank you chairman thank you miss cauley
council accordingly you'd like to
comment
[Music]
sorry about that i wasn't ready and yeah
um i propose acceptance i have a huge
amount of um
uh sympathy with the residents i think
they're
mainly not planning um in terms of
immunity
i think it's a good design um
in terms of um in fact i think it's
quite an attractive design the mansion
roof if i'm honest
um i do have concerns about the impact
on the residents themselves but i don't
think that's the planning
it will be in the construction um as
such
in terms of planning everything i hear
makes me feel that this is acceptable
and i'm happy to propose acceptance
thank you thank you council accordingly
counselor jerome
thank you chair um i also agree with
councillor accordingly
i think if you look at the objections
that have been uh raised
in in the uh to this application
they've been kind of fairly well
addressed by the um
the report the committee report um
and i think a lot of the objections
aren't
material as the report says um
such as uh one of the objections is
about increased insurance costs the
asbestos risk
um and the age of the building and also
that the properties will be devalued
but the these aren't really material um
to the application and and also
somebody talks about the the drainage
and flooding issues
um but there's actually um fairly
minimal
changes to the size of the roof so the
footprint of the building isn't changing
too much and
and um because the the surface of
area of the the roof isn't changing that
much that there'd be the same amount of
water runoff
um and
i can't see the parking problems being
that much of an issue
and i think they have been dealt with
really and also
there was the issue of of the bats as
well and we know there's been
emergent surveys done here and there is
a roost or
at one part of the summer that there is
roosting going on
and but that's been addressed as well um
and they've asked for the design to be
bat friendly and for there to be kind of
bat boxes
um so i
i'm agree with councillor accordingly
really
um and and will be supporting this
application
uh thanks jeff thank you councillor
jerome any other members wishing to
speak
um can i just say i went to view on
sunday and
the application it is out of keeping
with the area there's large roofs
uh around there on the buildings but
nobody's got um
got windows in them you know and dormer
windows so
it's going to be a big change and it's a
very settled community down there i can
well understand um why the neighbors
are upset what well established long
queue
but everybody knows each other everybody
gets on and the and this
to the neighbors is upsetting the apple
cart a bit
but i think council is wrong it's very
fair those those issues that are raised
and not so significant and certainly not
planning reasons well well we could
refuse it but it is a change in design
but
the distances involved no to the
properties on the other side on ingleby
court
that the the large distances and uh
wouldn't be so significant so i'm i'm
happy to support
uh the application it's been moved by
council accordingly that we grant this
application
are you happy to second the uh
application council of jerome
you have just hope i'm not putting words
in your mouth um
that's been moved and seconded that we
grant this application i'll go to the
votes
and council williams how would you like
to vote
uh to advance in line with officer
foundation thank you
recommendation thank you councillor
carey how would you like to vote
vote to grant please chairman thank you
very much councillor holden
thank you very much
um i'll vote to grant thank you thank
you councillor rigby
apologies councillor proctor
thank you very much councillor hartley
and chair votes grant thank you
councillor jerome
thank you councillor dr barclay
counselor dr barclay are you with us
she might have gone to another meeting
she's been very busy this evening
um council accordingly how would you
like to vote
grant chair thank you very much and i'll
be voting for grant
so for the people president that's
unanimous that we grant this application
that application has been granted thank
you everybody
for your contributions thank you to mr
rooney shaw and his uh
and his fellow neighbours for their
contribution there this evening
and that's what we're passed out
our our time 637 it is
um so we've still got some items left on
the agenda not not too many
um how are we proposing to deal with
those items uh
miss coley can you advise i can um
we're proposing to adjourn proceedings
this evening rather than complete them
and to reconvene
uh next thursday the 22nd
of october um at a time
to be agreed uh between those present
now if you want to close the meeting and
agree that time uh then we then we can
do so and have a have a
discussion about it um all we can or we
can
um agree that now yeah no we'll i think
we'll have a discussion board
everybody that's that's uh listening to
to
to hoping that their applications be
dealt with this evening apologies for
that but we've got a cut-off time
6 30 and we will get to those items i
was trying to
to put everybody was trying to get the
agenda push it along this evening but we
do need to consider all the issues i
think everybody's
application that we have spoken to have
been dealt with fairly and
and had the proper discussion and we'll
give your applications if you've not
been
uh had your surgery we'll give yours a
proper discussion again next week
so i'll close the meeting and just
before you do chairman if i could just
confirm to
anybody watching who's not had their
applications heard this evening that we
will confirm to you
the arrangements and the time for the
for the meeting next thursday when
after we've adjourned so you will be
given that information
in good time yes thank you for that miss
corey i'll close the meeting now
thank you